l'entreprise permaswage a souffert de la
crise sanitaire
la baisse de son activité a été
conséquente près de 40%
si les salariés s'attendaient à un plan
social avec une suppression de 60 postes
au départ aujourd'hui le projet est tout
autre il y a un plan social qui était
prévu avec des plans de départs
volontaires pour une quantité de 73
personnes et ensuite bassila
délocalisations se fait bas il y aura un
deuxième plan avec le reste tout le
reste du personnel qui ne veut pas aller
dans la drôme donc si on fait un bilan
ça nous fera à peu près 150 personnes
dans la compréhension face à la
délocalisation la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois a rencontré les
syndicats et le directeur général de la
société je lui ai fait part de mon
intérêt moment d'incompréhension des
difficultés qu'il serait amené à
rencontrer s'ils poursuivaient dans
cette délocalisation
néanmoins toute cette décision finale
lui appartient je peux comprendre une
réduction de charges donc une réduction
des effectifs
par contre absolument pas une
délocalisation totale en grève depuis
quinze jours les salariés sont debout
pour montrer leur désaccord face au
projet il espère encore pouvoir stopper
la délocalisation dont la drôme il est
conscient qu'il ya une situation
économique qui fait qu' il faut des
licenciements au fond une partie qui va
s'en aller avec des départs volontaires
etc
mais quelle complètement déplacé le site
en mode nous tous on croit que c'est
faisable pour que ça change c'est eto'o
qui s'endort il faut qu'on reste dehors
comme peu qu'on persiste et tant qu'on
n'a pas où on va pas lâcher on va lui
dire nous on est là on restera là
la direction n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions et s'est exprimé via un
communiqué elle justifie le plan social
par une baisse de commandes clients mais
explique avoir initié des discussions
avec les représentants syndicaux
d'ici le printemps 2000 21 73 postes
pourraient être supprimés et
l'entreprise délocaliser
a dreux
[Musique]